yes we've been trying to get some more
information uh Jane from the police
officers which are constantly walking
through here we've just seen several
members of the fire brigade walk through
with cutting equipment didn't look like
it it'd been used nobody is saying
anything and they said we cannot tell
you what's going on right now very
tight-lipped about what is going on
around in the study school and as you
said small Private Girls School a
beautiful location overlooking the
common and the golf course Wimbledon
Golf Course really popular and warning
spot for dog walkers I actually myself
thought my my dog there fairly often
it's it's a really quiet spot it's a
beautiful spot
huge lands for the golf course right in
front of that school with a couple of
small roads which come off the golf
course which go in the direction of the
school but they are extremely tiny as is
this road here very very small road
which goes down behind me around in
front of the school there's a couple of
beautiful residential houses around
there as well and then it comes around
the other side pretty much a sort of
mini one-way system if you like very
hard to imagine how anybody could get up
to a speed at all in a car I mean
normally it's five miles an hour 10
miles at most it is hard to imagine how
anyone's picked up any speed in a
vehicle at all they did tell us the
policeman told me when I arrived that it
was an out of control vehicle but he had
not been up to the school at a past the
police tape himself that's what he had
been told by his colleagues and out of
control vehicle as she said not
suspicious and not involving and the
vehicle
possibly it is towards the end of term
we have certainly seen one child walk
out of here a limping carried by both
her parents supporting her they looked
absolutely shell-shocked and couldn't
speak I just said a UK and her dad
nodded his head
the child couldn't speak at all they
couldn't tell us what had happened so
can you tell us what happened she said
no he shook his head again
looked absolutely shocked this is not
what you expect to happen around here
it's nowhere near a main road as you
said it's right in the middle of
Wimbledon common uh just a mile or so
away from the tennis but the response
has been massive I can see ambulances to
my left I can see at least two about
five meters away from our camera
position here I can see three fire
trucks four fire trucks and behind me
there have been at least 10 and is lined
up in Camp Road ready to take the engine
to hospital we've seen one ambulance
come through in the last couple of
minutes that has gone presumably going
straight to the local hospitals which
are the nearest to here
would be Saint George's in tooting and
Kingston Hospital would be the two main
hospitals closest to here there is
Parkside Private Hospital which is uh
fairly near but they would most likely
be taken to St George's Hospital from
this location but we'll wait to hear on
some more news as to exactly who's been
injured where they were injured how they
were injured and how this how this
horrible incident has happened so
to
the term
um
waiting to hear actually we understand
that a fire brigade a press officer has
gone through so waiting for more
information
hopefully fairly shortly but it's it's a
little bit sketchy at the moment because
nobody none of the responders here close
to us on the Police Court will tell us
very much detail about what's happened
and how many have been injured